Hawkeye and I
are working on a case.
Uh and we needed
to use the bathroom.
I, uh, he..
he did.
So, we were by the house
and we dropped in. No big deal.
Working on a case together?
-How terrific!
He's my partner.
We're not partners.
Well, we're
friends-slash-partners.
I wouldn't really describe
us as friends.
[phone beeps]
Someone used my laptop
to sign on to my work account,
ten minutes ago.
Any thoughts, Kate?
Hawkeye?
Oh, you'll...you'll never
get anything out of him.
See, CB1 has trouble opening up.
Uh, nobody calls me CB1.
I'm just trying it out
for a second.
Probably some early
childhood thing.
He thinks he doesn't tell me
much but he ends up
kind of telling me all of it.
-I virtually tell her nothing.
Um, but, yeah.
I think it's cause
I'm generally just pretty chill.
You know, not like,
“Oh my god! Hawkeye!”
Definitely not chill.
By the way, thank you
for saving the world.
Don't mention it.